So, where exactly did this annoying trend begin?
And more importantly, why?
Believe it or not, the way we use "like" can be traced back as far as the late 19th century.
Right here on the pages from the 1886 Scottish novel "Kidnapped"...
...by Robert Louis Stevenson.
But, it wasn't until the 1950s that a certain group...
...brought the word to spotlight: The Beat Generation.
The young, rebellious Beat Generation...
...soon picked up the interjection as a sign of cool,...
...and it was used so frequently that it turned into a trope...
...for any beatnik character in pop culture.
The Beats played an important role...
...in introducing the new use of "like" to a larger audience,...
...especially the younger generations.
And 20 years later, when the word rose to prominence once again,...
...it wasn't from the rebellious Beat writers in bars,...
...but from the young girls in the malls of San Fernando Valley.
And they had a name for themselves.
They are Valley Girl!
The Valley Girl was a socioeconomic stereotype...
...referring to the young upper-class white girls...
...living in the San Fernando Valley.
These girls were known for spending days at the mall...
...and dressing head to toe in pink.
But, what stood out the most was the way they spoke.
Barf out, I am sure!
It even had its own name: Valley speak.
It was what linguists call a sociolect,...
...a set of dialect, slang, and words used by a specific class of people.
It includes words and phrases like tubular, totally, grody, gag me with a spoon,...
...some of which are still used today.
And of course, the word "like."